[Laughter]
i'm a perfectly normal spencer jay
gilbert i'm here with danielle per usual
here to talk about um the usual uh
netflix has made a movie that you will
watch and never speak of again but it's
our job to keep talking about it it's
the gray man folks you know it you love
it uh you saw it according to netflix
but i am starting to watch that yeah um
frank grayman fbi
i wish
uh we'll we'll give you our uh more
detailed thoughts on it we're gonna
watch the trailer together we have some
deleted scenes we will do q a so keep
those questions coming in the chat and
then we'll tease you with next week's
much more exciting honest trailer so
stick around for that one yeah um the
gray man i
i think i
have been piling on the grey man or it
hit me a little harder um just because
of the hollywood context that it exists
in i don't think it's a terrible film
it's not a great film um it's i wouldn't
even say for me an enjoyable one but it
was fine i was fine to watch that said
i feel like going to the movies or or
streaming stuff these days
it's like i'm on this is cake
but it's like is it it's like i'm on is
it cake yeah and every movie they cut it
they cut into it and oh it's the same
this is a born movie but put through the
marvel filters
exactly the marvelized born it's the
marvelization of every other genre um
coming soon dungeons and dragons now
that looks like a red now the spy the
spy genre red notices uh
red notice has some marvelization going
on of the adventure genre
we're not going to get into red notice
again
great man has that too but there's just
a i feel like this genre of
well i was going to say mid-budget but
this was the most expensive this
shouldn't be a huge but there was no
reason for this movie to be 200 million
dollars except for talent digital smoke
it's all smoke it's all smoke but yeah
this genre used to be like where you
could just show off your style uh like
and in a unique way you the the michael
manns of the world the uh john mctiernan
michael's the days of the world even the
michael bay's got in their start on
stuff like bad boys is this was a way to
show off and to flex your your action
sequence chops yes and your kind of
ability to get uh heightened fun
performances out of maybe some lesser
known actors like maybe you discover uh
you discover
bruce willis or something like that or
yeah but this is just taking if you
think of like like robert rodriguez when
he made el mariachi and desperado like
that was you're trying to create
sequences that are like a calling card
like oh that guy jumping in slow motion
firing two guns off the roof of a
building that's a cool shot i haven't
seen that anywhere else and like yeah to
me that's what it feels like is lacking
here like i think this movie is fine the
story's fine the script is fine the
jokes are fine everything would have
been okay the action sucks like and if
there were memorable cool kinetic
energetic interesting compelling action
scenes everything else would be
yeah it just it feels like every time
it's about to get really interesting
again we joked about like all of a
sudden there's smoke or all of a sudden
somehow they find the one piece of
shadow that's like in this incredibly
lit up yes
like during fireworks it's like oh look
there's a shadow now i can't see
anyone's hands and so every time it
seems like we're going to get a really
interesting piece of action it is
obscured or it's shot in such a way
where it's like i have no idea what's
going on airplane there's a scene in an
airplane where eventually the airplane
goes down and it's very chaotically sort
of realized with gosling falling and
then he survives by grabbing another guy
in his parish i guess we don't see him
and then we leave him in midair but uh
even just during the fight on the plane
before the plane gets destroyed there's
purple smoke for no good reason we're
looking at their feet a lot of the time
even when they're not kicking like
they're they're punching each other and
throwing each other but we're watching
their feet for no reason and then they
do this shot that they do a few other
times at the movie too where gossip will
be about to land a punch and we'll cut
to behind his back so we see his body
moving in the direction that he's
punching but we don't see the punches
land and it's just like this just feels
like fundamental action filmmaking like
you want to keep the camera at a place
where we could clearly see who's hitting
who and where they are in relation to
each other and it just feels like i
wonder if this is i mean i know
obviously the the russos are getting the
the bulk of our ire here but i wonder
because they're using
huge celebrities chris evans and ryan
gosling like
not saying they wouldn't be willing to
put in the work but this is why you
usually cast like
whoever's in the raid like martial
artists
these people don't have time
they're not necessarily interest but to
rehearse what you need to do is spend
months rehearsing yes like nine
different action scenes for them to film
it legibly because like extraction which
the russo's produced with chris
hemsworth that has a lot of great
looking action scenes and clearly
hemsworth is doing a lot there was
there's a scene uh where gosling is is
like sort of watching out for this girl
julie butters from once upon
uh and a guy like an assassin comes to
her house and he like fights the
assassin like right outside her bedroom
door and that scene is actually like you
get a pretty good medium shot so you can
see and gosling is clearly doing the
move so i i'm i'm hesitant to blame ryan
gosling because it does look like he
tried his best to like
do the action in a way that was
competent it just feels like they kind
of don't know where to put the camera
i'm just saying there's like 13 action
sequences and he's also filming ken yeah
you know you look at there are great
action sequences in winter soldier like
i'm not a huge fan of some of their
other marvel movies but this there's
they've never made one that i feel like
the action was this
underwhelming and so i'm not sure what
happened here uh i'm just there for the
for the spy intrigue who of um in the
cia is a bad person um let's watch our
own stream there's a lot of that too
yeah that's not true
who stole
in a world where audiences will only
show up for marvel movies netflix will
hire some marvel directors marvel
writers and marvel actors to marvelize
the spy genre by let's say about fifteen
percent you must be loyal what gave it
away the white pants the trash dash it
just
it leans lloyd oh yeah give me that good
snark i get at your glib
the gray man
that was the moment when billy bob goes
i get it you're glib i was like i'm not
going to like this
that was it right
it is the opening scene
so that just happened yes like oh okay
we're all ready so the thing is oh gray
man is there a purple man
that's that's all i need to do they did
they made a joke about it they didn't
they did make a bunch of jokes about his
name
could you be any more named after
no at one point they do like the the
nanny or whatever of the um the what is
it the sick orphan girl yeah um the in
any of the sick orphan girl at one point
is like leave mr number alone or
something like that
marcus mcfeely i mean a beautiful name
for a girl seven i feel like what their
skill set is is balancing
24 main characters so that everybody
just has to get like one little line in
one little moment and then you can move
on but when they only have three they're
like oh crap oh
oh god more snark yeah i i mean like
there's several whole people in this who
don't really get a personality like main
characters who are just like they just
have one mode it's pretty underwhelming
and i can't imagine look i have not read
the books but i can't imagine that um
you know uh six is is cracking wise and
and doing snarky comebacks in the 90s
airport novel but maybe maybe i could be
wrong i mean i i should have called my
dad
i bet my dad's read it i should have
called her yeah that's actually one of
the things that i think played for me in
the i thought gosling's very deadpan it
a little bit reminded me of him in the
nice guys and i like that mode for him
like i felt like this character
gosling's character specifically in a
different movie with better action
scenes and a different supporting cast
might have worked for me so a different
movie a different one but the guy i like
with the gazing performance in this i
did not mind at all interesting i
thought that was the the i liked all the
other ones but let's keep going
went from directing this
[Music]
to directing this
and then cherry
[Laughter]
yay
now the rubros are back armed with the
rights to one of those books your dad
buys at the airport but instead of
falling asleep on a neck pillow after
two chapters in a ginger ale you'll fall
asleep on your couch while netflix burns
200 million bucks in the background
pink sauce
you've seen ryan gosling play a cool
silent driver
cool silent astronaut
and cool silent future detective
but you've never seen him play a cool
silent criminal before have you
good movie yeah
okay cool silent criminal turned off the
book cia assassin how's that they made
me stay in bed
how long they make you stay in bed for
quite a long time several weeks actually
oh i hope you're okay you're better now
six thanks for pause
i said it uh i said earlier i think on
slack or something about how ryan
gosling is is the modern day chicken boo
[Laughter]
everyone's like oh you're so handsome
right now like one person's like he's a
chicken
carry them off from the straight jacket
yeah uh yeah he has a lot of roles where
he doesn't talk yeah
silent type yeah emphasis on the silence
i like that in drive uh he had a lot of
dialogue in the script and they shot it
all and then in the edit room nicholas
whitney griffin was like you know what
would be great is if he just never said
really and like cut out so there's a cut
of drive where he talking cut he just
chats like he's just like a regular guy
who's chatting and then they they
systematically cut like all of that out
so he's just like very very quiet he's
just talking about cars that's true i
wanna well the mazda is the artist
that's a good engine buddy how much he
loves coronas and family the whole time
it's really weird maybe i would like
that movie more i'm sorry i know
everyone likes drive i'm wrong it's fine
it's great i don't like it it's stylish
i like it it's very pretty it's very
pretty exactly it's very beautiful
that's another movie where the action
like it doesn't feel like they have to
cut around ryan gosling not knowing how
to throw a punch which is make what
makes me so dubious about the way this
one said okay
uh okay keep going as he transforms into
sierra 6 a character who lives in that
gray area between jason bourne and jason
bourne with mono that's the most sleep
i've had in 36 hours need anything
just a nap and follow along as he kicks
to monaco to chiang mai to london to
hong kong to vienna to berlin to croatia
back to frog to washington dc
wow those are big titles
if that's your calling card you gotta
take a long look in the mirror it's like
john woo two guns and doves you know
michael bay explosions of the magic hour
russo brothers large locationary big
title cards text
i like that sometimes they just do like
vienna like everybody knows that's
austria we don't have to but whoa whoa
whoa i'm sorry uh line you could not id
vienna without a you can identify the
skyline of vienna with no no no i'm
saying i'm saying they're all title
cards but sometimes they just put the
city name and then sometimes when it's
baku they're like put put azerbaijan
under it people don't know
these dummies don't know where baku but
like but they only trust you sometimes
they're gonna be very disoriented
berlin figure it out
my father fancied himself for real macho
man and uh
he started laying into my brother so
wait all he did was shoot his dad he's a
florida man that's like nothing
it's group
okay yeah um i just feel like
i'm now uh this is becoming a little
soapbox thing but when i found out carol
danvers is from boston
is finding out that uh ryan gosling's
character is from is a criminal in 2003
era florida with bleached hair
like there's something there you can't
just ignore that like was this guy like
uh was he groomed by lou pearlman and
then he shot him because like he
wouldn't let him go solo from the boy
band or
if you don't have a take on uh like a
location specific idea about your
character just make them be from
evansville or like or don't say or just
don't put a title card everywhere yeah
you just don't we don't have to do that
like every it would be like if every
single time we do a cut on one of these
like someone puts up a like danielle
left side of screen like it's not
necessary we get it everyone knows yeah
retain the mystery there's nothing it's
like when um
the born movies got so much more
interesting when you found out his name
was like
don pudd from alabama
or whatever well it's also they're not
using any like none of these sequences
are shot in places that really showcase
this like it doesn't matter that that's
in vienna or croatia or baku like who
cares it could just be a different city
like they're trying to impress us like
we went all over the world yeah these
spy thrillers are generally
globetrotting so i guess we gotta try
yeah but it's not true but you're not it
doesn't matter like you know like the
classic bond movies it wouldn't just be
like he goes somewhere it'd be like if
he goes to cairo yeah he's going to he's
going to fight on top of the sphinx you
know
he's like he's punching a guy from one
pyramid to the other you know like use
the location like what's the point of
going there if you're not going to make
it look like itself yeah um i thought
that the opening sequence i had higher
hopes where he was in i guess thailand
or was it banking
i think it's bangkok because then he
flees to chiang mai yeah
that was promising but you're right
everything did turn a little gray after
that um location-wise a little bit oh
well yeah all right keep going
florida man
hot on his trail is stupid sexy flanders
wait i mean boyd handsome no i mean
lloyd hanson god those cakes are
distracting
[Music]
chris evans sorry
who clearly watched a bunch of nick cage
to prep for the job would someone mind
shooting the man handcuffed to the bench
because i got shot in the ass suzanne
w xy3 morons
follow the relentless game of dad and
mouse as six must risk his life to save
his ex boss's niece i think and uh
when you really uh pull back from this
um this is uh he's risking his life uh
killing scores and scores of people
because the guy who recruited him into
basically the suicide squad yeah and
then abandoned him yeah
we never got that far
he's like was there ever a plan to like
get me out of this when i was done
assassinated like no no you're just
gonna die and we'd deny all knowledge
but uh that's that's on me that's my bad
i do have a niece
i ever seen that tammy crap sketch i
think you should leave
have you noticed my mug that says number
one uncle i take unclean very seriously
very seriously yeah i have what's known
as uncle magic
that just
i this they always they always do this
thing where it's like oh you know
suddenly by the end of the movie
everyone is family and in this one they
don't even bother like showing us that
connection she literally says like oh
well if he's like my dad and he's like
your dad i guess that means we're family
too and he just pops his gum at her and
it's like okay well i guess now the
movie's about the orphan with the heart
condition it's also the age gap between
billy bob thornton and his sibling who
had julia butter since their child
that's like that's he's he's got a
50-year age difference from his uh
brother or sister i have a very
flandering uh brother uh a child that's
mick jagger
you know we should really be
investigating that i think we should
pause it what's going on with my brother
it doesn't seem right let's do a
flashback you're a little young to be a
like great niece maybe knoxville
there we are a suspiciously old father
or young brother it's unclear very weird
so many different oh i i just filled in
a she great these she's he's great great
thank you there you go
maybe it was i imagine his nephew's shy
i i would wager that in the book that's
his billy bob's daughter but they just
happened to be able to cast billy they
wanted to cast billy it definitely is
something like they want to kiss billy
bob so he's got it he's an older look
i'ma just say it i think his boys still
swim i'd buy it
but we're not talking about him we're
talking about his sibling yes that's
what i'm saying i think that that could
have been billy bob he's got a very
virile brother well no i'm saying billy
bob uh you're right billy bob could get
it he could get it at in his advice he
could you could have just
eia has done some shady stuff in the
past we're going to prison for this no
you really aren't this committee and
myself have decided to exonerate the
three of you in this section yeah pause
but
the flash drive that they're all
fighting over contains evidence that the
head of the cia assassination department
was was engaged in bombings and
assassinations the cia literally
assassinated somebody earlier this week
and the president had like a ra raw fist
pump press conference
like it's that's not that weird i don't
know
i don't know if we'd all be that upset i
i i
i
we all know the cia is the cia i don't
feel like anybody agent has ever looked
at a screen and been like we're all
going to prison for this like ever i
don't feel like that's ever once
happened like wow
that's like if someone had a flash drive
that what they were hiding from the fbi
and on there it is the fbi wears suits
yeah like we know like that's your dude
i guess that there was
maybe there is a attempt at like some
meta commentary or or humor there at the
end where they all get off scot-free
because he did cat that was a director
cameo
that's joe russo right there to be like
but then that that gives us basically
the same ending as burn after reading
where it's like what did we learn
nothing like so why are we even
bothering you
no reason
we don't want this to get out of my head
i might have a headline somewhere in a
daily beast might write about this yeah
well it also is they have to kind of
reset everything to zero because we got
you you gotta you gotta lay the
groundwork for your your agreement too
for beijing back back to beijing
well we were we had a we had a dark uh
theory um that this was part of
netflix's color universe of red notice
grey man and there would be another
there'd be like blue valentine and then
they'd all cross over yeah well you know
you got red man rapper red man man group
got a mr green gotta get got a lot more
movies in this franchise oh man i would
love to watch the russo uh cia globe
trotting blue man group movie yeah
this is a job for the blue man
those guys are very rich good for them
catching grenades in one another's
mouths
keep going
for action scenes that push the
boundaries of how much smoke and debris
you can hide the action behind
that cuts around like a taken three
editor on ritalin
with the occasional clearly shot scene
to show that yeah gosling does have
moves
all this other crap is on purpose
you know not bad but how would it look
with some random drone shots mixed in
like they're being attacked by a bird
got it
enter a world shrouded in mystery
raising tons of unanswered questions for
the already greenlit sequels like why is
jessica henwick stuck in the person
behind a bank of monitor's role why did
bridgerton leave his hit show to take
the other person behind a bank of
monitor's role why do all the spies keep
exploding
since when did likes gone become a
personality trait bubblicious watermelon
wave what do you say there is no other
kind of cake or you can just go with the
buffalicious jesus no that's just
bubbling yum can someone go to harvard
without forcing it into every
conversation i went from harvard to
analysis to the do's desk in eight years
no one goes to harvard to play football
you did we all went to harvard together
and wouldn't have worked better bernie
harlan directed in the 90s with like
christian slater and john travolta hell
yeah yeah come on you know what it would
be hello
as as this is going on to say all of
these questions will be answered because
we're getting more graement yeah we're
going to bring so much agreement
although you know it's kind of a i don't
know if they're in production already
because i'll kind of believe it when i
see it because i thought we're getting a
whole brighter verse um well they
there there has been talk about did
netflix release that news instead of you
know usually within a few days of uh a
big release like this you'd get the
gray man set all these new view records
and it's the biggest netflix movie we
didn't get those articles this time
instead we got this weird one that it's
like it's their fifth biggest opening
weekend for any english language
original film behind kissing booth three
which already was like that's a little
weird that sentence is too long
once you get to the end of it you know
you have nothing yeah and then the the
like the next day it was netflix green
lights two more grey men movies so like
it feels like it might be a little bit
of a like look over here don't don't
don't think about how well or badly the
grey man did think about oh it must have
done well because we already greenlit
and then you know they could always just
not look like they can take another
another swing at this but i feel like
they can't keep throwing 200 million
dollars no you can't i mean sure if you
need to bring well you can't bring back
evans
i mean you could if it's a prequel well
it's a prequel so that though it is it's
one
they announced two movies a prequel and
a sequel they haven't said what they are
but i think we can presume the prequel
is probably evans yeah prior to this and
the sequel would be goslings
okay so that would be my guess okay so
then it's only 20 million dollars for
your star instead of 40 million dollars
like it was right they're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna split these two okay
right all right you're freeing up some
cash there and then they said that i
think that that um i think it was vienna
the the scene the shootout in the city
square big trains yeah that was like for
another 40 million dollars i'm i'm
losing track of that that's what they
said they said that sequence alone was
40 million the the the chase through
vienna followed by the train but the
most inventive moment of that entire
sequence i thought was when he shoots
somebody by looking in the reflection in
the mirror yeah which
is why so many uh of these films have
halls of mirrors
because it's a lot cheaper to just have
a shootout in a hall of mirrors like
john wick yeah
they always come down they love they
love we love a hollow we love all
americans
that's cool yeah i feel like it's lady
from shanghai i think i think orson
welles kind of pioneered that yeah that
sequence there's the bruce lee
i don't i don't remember which one uh oh
yeah is that game of death i think it's
that one where at the end there's a
fight
um i think it i don't know you're right
mate i don't i remember the sequence i
don't remember which bruce lee movie uh
us
uh there's it's not a fight but they do
there is a hollow mirror isn't it yeah
anyways uh they're cheap weekend super
bowl performance
[Laughter]
from the twisted mind of the weekend
for the twisted mind of the weekend
i hope he got out uh he's still watching
he's still in there
all right keep playing
alex is in a desperate search for the
next mega hit they're throwing
everything they've got at a franchise
that's like bond without the style below
seven was taken mission impossible
without the real stars
what is that and marble without the ip
yeah
because at their core netflix knows
they're just one bad quarter away from
becoming red box without the p smell
oh yeah there you go yeah um nice job
kevin uh mocking up the netflix
yeah i think that might be our futures
where we just go into a uh kind of like
the suicide booth from futurama where we
just
get inside there and then they just
stream uh you know whatever red notice
came out that week yeah you play the
squid game and then they let you out if
you win yeah that's the new did you see
that there's an immersive interactive
squid game uh
experience coming to like several u.s
cities
where you go into like a pod and like
the
touch screen walls and you play squid
games yeah i mean i'm going to write
something about just like the worst ways
to kill people and then see how quickly
i can turn it into an activation
like come play this quick game like no
they all die it's terrible
they don't have a good time playing the
squid game now if you guys watch that
show um
you just got me thinking about how much
i missed playing laser tag that's what
coven really took for me yeah
because i feel like we used to be a
country you made it in 2019 you were
still playing
every
weekend wow yeah i had my tactical
fedora oh my god i had it all set still
i had my my alias my buds my my taggers
yeah i mean i guess there has to have
still been a lively laser tag community
i feel like i've recently played laser
tag oh really wow wow not like i'm not
post nothing you live in a smoke-filled
warehouse a long time i live in gray
notice perfect
uh anyways um is that it no we have
starring we've had yeah let's
fitzroy and the tantrums gringerton
iron pist that was the best acting i've
ever seen
wait ucia contractors are killing people
that's it i'm out i don't care about the
money anymore these are not honorable
people and okay i surrender haha
okay
okay
[Laughter]
right right you got me
that's day one of cia's by school
born again
yeah
every grade a wet team from here they
could be vine for the prestige of
killing the infamous year six there's
your spin-off the icelandic team no one
believes in until the world is overrun
by elves and ferry oh crap i just
pitched bright too didn't i never mind i
love a grade a wet team from reykjavik i
just want that in that line rent-free in
my head
no come on that was where it like gets
hammy and like crosses over into
something enjoyable i wanted more of
that yeah it's such a try hard
it's just like these was that supposed
to be scary well it's supposed to no
it's i thought that he was uh the most
fun part of the movie for me i thought
it was i i don't know i have to i have
to buy it like nicholas cage will play
that character but you buy it you buy
this guy is that crazy like this feels
like such a movie character to me and
it's not chris evans chris evans has
played like over-the-top smarmy
jerks like
you know scott pilgrim or whatever like
he's good at that role it just it felt
overwritten like this guy is just it's
too much and it's showing off and i
don't know i i just enjoyed watching i
like watching him in that mode uh
um the knives out mode better than uh
but knives out like he sells you on you
believe he's that particular strain of
[ __ ] and this one it felt like when
he left you in that movie yeah that's
what i felt like when he was doing that
dialogue all i could hear was like
nicholas cage in the rock like how in
the name of zeus's butthole like it
feels like that's what they're writing
and i don't know he didn't sell me on it
the way cage would yeah well
you liked it right yeah well no because
i like well for obviously first chris
evans and yes you are welcome obviously
i'm the one who tracked all the butt
shots
you're welcome
but so we uh
that was the chris evans that i liked
like when he was cast as captain america
i was like this doesn't feel like a good
fit and then it wound up being great but
i this is i like the smarmy chris evans
this is this was always return to smarm
return to smart um
thank you all for watching uh like
subscribe hit the bell so you don't miss
another announcement we are putting
together i'm reading a uh san diego
comic-con playlist
uh me and uh carolyn we're here uh doing
some some panel reactions but we also
did a whole bunch of interviews
uh that we're uh doling out to you um to
feed your addiction to content so
so uh that should be coming soon and
being posted every day also check out
our twitch channel uh fandom.tv
uh backslash uh wait
i haven't gotten any sleep twitch.tv
backslash fandom uh where we will be
watching uh let's let's track down
robosaurus i think oh trouble we should
probably watch
sure the um the detective's kid dies and
gets reincarnated as a robot dinosaur
has a robot but it grows that's what's
soaking it also grows
it's very confusing because it is a
robot which you would see like a toy set
amount of mass yeah but then when danger
is near it grows into like robust like
the actual robosaurus i love that
afterwards can we watch i gotta find the
name of this movie it's that great movie
with mario van peebles where they're
werewolf cops okay well yeah we could do
werewolf cops for sure mario mvp
werewolves cops but i think that i would
like to do a film series on different
people who die and whose soul gets
trapped in a funny thing
i think we could do a whole film soon
maybe we'll just do one marathon and
then we'll do the filmography of mario
van people yeah we have two
jack frost top of the list uh i was
gonna go solo i like i'm a solo man yeah
but i mean jack frost got to put it
because he dies in his soul ends up oh
first oh
i was see i'm i'm still in mvp land
you're talking about oh i was saying it
gets trapped yeah it dies and then soul
gets trapped in objects
jack frost is like maybe the greatest
example
the second only to the love-o-matic
grandpa
well that's very direct parody of my
mother the car
uh
we learned things folks um so uh here's
some questions questions and comments uh
evan j pretzel welcome back oh outro
thank you for the reminder yeah let's uh
let's see those starring
the nice guys only gauze forgives bland
runner
skis rogers that's america's asset
no time to try
ormus of one if it doesn't fit you must
acquits
six slays seven fights
captain america six ah i get it
that's it yeah sweet uh we use we use
every part we'll use every part of the
grey man
when you kill a movie you have to make
sure that you use every part of the
movie so evan asks uh in light of evan's
mustache what entertainer or character
are you giving or taking away facial
hair from oh
wow
entertainer or character
yeah
you know who looks really good with like
an old timey mustache is john c reilly
like in like gangs in new york when he's
got that like irish cop stash like
that's a that's a good look yeah i would
i would keep the mustache for john cena
okay that's a really good one um
i mean i just need to see it one time i
need i need it to happen so i can get it
out of my brain we got to take harvey's
stash right steve harvey's mustache has
to go
it has to go just so we can see it just
so we can see what's happening under the
smithsonian yeah okay it belongs in a
museum wow we do an upper lip reveal on
youtube yes he would make a shocked and
befuddled face if you were here in here
to hear that right now
um i want to give a
chalamet like a van dyke i want to give
him like
[Laughter]
yeah
uh all right so
um benjamin brownwood's asked how are
cinephiles gonna feel in march 2023 when
the russos accept a best picture oscar
for producing everything everywhere all
at once well there you go i mean they've
produced that they produced uh like the
that extraction movie that i liked yeah
probably the cooler version of of this
um i got nothing against joe and anthony
as a guy like i'd like to make that
perfectly this is not a hatred for the
russos
in particular as people uh no i love a
rescue i would feel great
yeah
if they i mean i'd be like wow best
picture huh but that'd be awesome if
they
got an oscar for that yeah it'd be great
i bear them that is that is a picture
that they are a part of that should
probably get an oscar yeah and i was i
like i went into this
not thinking boo boy here we go like i
thought this was going to happen cool
actually i was i was just i know this
was the it was the is it cake uh
experience i never go into a movie
wanting to hate it i want movies to be
good yes movies being good is better
than them being bad yeah right
so i would feel i would feel great about
that i would have no problem i mean i
feel like they would probably let the
daniels give the acceptance speech but
that i would i would be fine with them
being on stage and if they said you know
what our next project is like we're
gonna go back to tv comedy that's great
too i would be like that's that's
awesome
development
but whatever whatever another season of
community sure yeah um
all right uh
may says didn't we praise the russo and
winter soldiers specifically for not
doing action scenes like taken oh did
you yeah i guess so it's an intentional
reference i don't remember but yes
yes
do you remember things you got because
that was before my time even writing on
his trailers winter soldier yeah there's
no way i rode on the on the winner
trailer on us no
but we have long used in uh it must show
up like five times is the taken three
liam neeson
um yeah it's like a famously over-edited
yeah we've used that a lot so i i
wouldn't be surprised anything that cuts
a lot we probably cut to that um
but that's a much better at like there
are much better action sequences than
that i i think like yeah
uh radar city update channel asks uh
daniel what would you spend 200 million
dollars on
oh
wow you have to spend it and you can't
give it to anything good crypto
let's just say let's just get this out
of the way that we'd all give it to
charity
obviously i would solve world hunger but
if world hunger is off the table it's
off the table it's off the table what
would i spend 200 million dollars on
well the first thing i'm going to do i
think is probably
buy a small town fill it with children
and give them all jobs you're doing
kidnapping yeah
i want to see how quickly it becomes
like lord of the flies um
uh and adults will be around um
supervising but mostly just like you
know they'll all go to like a a shoppie
that they like and they'll like be
friends with the man that pours their
sodas um so that's what that's 40
million um the next 40 million i would
probably spend on um
oh i think uh i'd probably buy
my mom nope can't do anything good with
it um
next 40 million um just hiring a team uh
professional hair and makeup and then
just one man
to
shower me with palm fronds just
constantly fanning me and feeding me
peeled grapes yeah i mean that's a given
yeah yeah like obviously um oh i can get
one of those things where like people
have to like carry me like yeah um not
like a stretcher that's not a palette
that's uh yeah what is that called uh
yeah you want to be part of a
processional i want to be part of a
professional everywhere i go raise
platforms um so that's another and then
i think the rest of it um eventually
oh
i
who do you think is this i would use it
like cameo except for cameo i'm allowed
to go up to any celebrity i want and
then just like
slap him in the face okay
okay
i thought i was gonna get weird didn't
you no i chose violence instead of being
a performer at these low low prices then
y'all can hit i like that
and you inspired me because i want to
start a service where it's like i will
be um kind of a eccentric uh 200
millionaire and i will pay celebrities i
have respect for to leave cameo i'll say
what are you making from cameo it's
embarrassing that you're on there i want
you up here
take this let's hurry you don't have to
wish everybody a happy father's day or
whatever like here you go here's the
money
for some more news we just got a cameo
from uh lost actor terry o'quinn and he
did such a good job
oh i don't i don't want him to feel bad
about making i'm like the johnny
appleseed of getting celebrities off
i feel like there's there's like the
celebrities who don't take it seriously
who are just like in their hallway like
heading out that that they should be off
cameo okay but there are there's a
certain breed of celebrities you're
saying it's giving birth to like a real
craft yeah i mean there's a crap
some people are really bringing it to
cameo and i have nothing but respect for
this diffraction
has a great cameo yeah
a mark mcgrath cameo for our friend
who's not a mark mcgrath fan uh or sugar
ray fan in any form but uh she's a well
she's a she's a woman and we sent uh we
sent mark mcgrath the most attractive
picture we could find of this girl and
said she was obsessed with mark mcgrath
sure yeah and just absolutely loved
everything about them and he sang two
songs with her name two famous sugar ray
songs working her name into the music
put your arms around me girl's name put
your arms around me
yeah and every morning there's a halogen
girl's name
he really brought it yeah oh i bet you
feel like crap
not really yeah
you paid for a service it's hilarious um
so
sam levine friend of the show also uh he
he has a service where he will uh give
people bad news for you
oh so if you want if you want to deliver
a crushing blow to someone in your life
sam levine will do that mark mcgrath
also broke up with someone for someone
oh yeah
yeah you're right he is taking it to the
next level right so those people i think
should be allowed but i i i get i take
your meeting people who aren't really
making it how we're clearly on cameo
just for the dollars yes that's do you
have a uh do you have a 200 million
dollar i'd like to go back to some of
like uh mr beast's greatest hits and
like just spend a little bit more money
than he did
i'm gonna make my own squid game but i'm
gonna spend two million dollars more
than mr beast yeah take that jimmy
oh i'm the number one youtuber not
anymore i got 200 million dollars
i'm just i'm just kidding nice who who
would have a problem with mr beast um
it takes a big sip of coffee uh
who could have a problem uh
pericles dragon balls asks have you read
any spy novels that haven't been adapted
but you'd like to see get adapted if yes
which ones and i've got one then oh
really uh well
i don't really read a lot of spines i
don't anymore um but when i was in i
think sixth or seventh grade i read um
the secret man by frank dukes ducks
dukes isn't that wait the guy from
bloodsport 100 the guy from bloodsport
and a hundred percent a complete artist
yeah absolutely bullshitting about like
yeah i've got 38 confirmed kills but no
i can't one
he says he wrote in a book a
autobiography that he won the coumadin
also this made a big impression on me in
sixth grade uh he he was in an office
with a with a sexy lady and he set off
the spread the fire alarm sprinklers and
melted her shirt off with water and then
they made love under the sprinklers of
the fire
that
i think he is a music video when he was
on opium in in thailand didn't sound
like a real story so yes i would adapt
the secret man by frank dukes a
completely invented autobiography uh
which i mean it might as well be a
spinal what's the name of that bill
o'reilly novel those who take the pass
yeah it's very much like that's the one
that's the one yeah i would just do
james bond jr it's not a novel but i
would like to see it animated i would
like to see it on screen i read that's
that's always my thing is like i end up
reading like if i saw a spy movie i
liked like i read a bunch of the bond
novels
but i've never like
read spy novels on my own really yeah
not not my favorite show well uh do you
want to talk about uh
reggie jean page at all or do we want to
talk about snacks
for our final question
he's hot and he was misused in this
movie there you go i don't i just why
would anybody want to play like like cia
weasel is such a generic role like we've
seen it's not that he's bad he doesn't
do a bad job but we just seen like every
every character actor in hollywood has
played cia weasel a few times it's just
like one of those like what a waste of
charms i assume in like book four he he
gets out of the yeah from behind the
desk
it's just like all right you know like
we've we've seen this so reynard again
um
if you were on lad bite what's lad bible
he says if you were on landmine
what snacks would you bring with you you
know like a funny humor blog kind of
thing okay why would i
do this i i just want to talk about the
snacks but this is live bible
what's next i don't know what that i
don't know what that means okay if you
were on lad bible i think it's like it's
a website but i'm bringing the trader
joe's peanut butter filled pretzels
that's what i'm bringing because i can't
open a bag of that without without
crushing it um that's probably my
preferred my number one snack right now
um i i'm a big fan of trail mix i love a
trail mix um sometimes i'll just eat
like some trail mix for breakfast um
what is just seems like a way for me to
like
you know um
class up some m m's because that's no it
is it's just an excuse to eat eminem's
breakfast
i'm healthy
you eat this on the trail you're not on
a trail danielle you're at your desk at
home with a cat like you're not you're
not hiking the trails okay i think there
it seems like a lad bible does a show
where they bring americans on and then
they give you british snacks so it's
always like like
one of
right it's like what's what's an
american snack that you would showcase
to an international audience i think is
the question great question fun dip
yeah with no instructions yes yeah just
like why is the stick the stick's edible
yeah eat the stick it's america the
stick is also sugar yeah yeah that would
be a good one um
oh i think a snack that i would bring to
introduce people to the idea uh man i'm
just so
i'm so basic i think it would probably
be like peach rings oh yeah i love a
good pizza pj yeah uh i think it's it's
got to be those those crackers that come
in the little plastic
you got the little red stick that you
spread the cheese the disgusting process
cheese smear on the crackers yeah and in
this case the snack the stick is not
edible no no no
red piece of strip of plastic yeah
americans very confusing um speaking of
silly americans for next week's honest
trailer we're finally
venturing outside our bubble our our
hollywood bubble have we done an
international
expanding the scope we're going
worldwide folks um
and
gosh we can't wait yeah like pitbull
yeah
um that's your clue uh for next week's
we can't wait we hope to see you then
thanks for watching see ya
[Music]
[Music]
you